- Colossal Clusterfest.
- We made it.
- Hell yeah, let's go.
(upbeat music)
- Is that the famous dog?
- You can come up.
- Isn't that crazy that
that's the Kevin Hart of dogs?
- Thank you for interviewing
me, I am Gorburger.
- Who are you excited
to see at the festival?
- The Gorburger show!
(upbeat music)
- [Megan] I guess
we gotta get food.
- Good thing about the festival
is there's a ton of options.
Is this the size of the salad?
- It's a big salad!
- [Megan] That's how big it is?
- [Ramon] Racial
harmony in a cookie.
- [Cook] Look to
the cookie, man.
- [Megan] Hey, can I
have some of your pizza?
- Yeah, can I not have
any of your taco?
- You can have.
Sounds like a great deal.
- Cheers.
- Can I get a
lobster, a crab bisc?
- Don't you know what you want?!
No soup for you!
(laughing)
- It's hard dancing this burly.
I wonder how people do it at
music festivals all the time.
Ooh, do you wanna
go to Paddy's Pub?
(chanting)
- Yes, yes, yes!
(people cheering)
- This has truly been colossal.
- We'll see you next
year Clusterfest.
- You tired?
- Yeah, can you carry me?
- Of course.
- After party at Alcatraz!